please say hello to the talented the
humble running back Maurice jones-drew
yeah mojo yes that a fair transition me
come gets up early I don't I don't have
to worry about a bomb back anything I do
is gonna be fine that's very very alike
are you a fan of stand-up comedy yeah I
think anytime you can make people laugh
is gonna be okay
but you don't go to you don't go to
these places you know no III have three
kids young dogs a bunny and a cats I
don't have much time to do much of
anything but work it's great to have you
on in person here I love our
conversations and lent I can do the foam
formal introduction 8,000 career yards
in nine years sixty eight touchdowns if
I was gonna show one highlight that
summed up your career that highlight
would be uh I think the most popular one
is Shawne Merriman is getting after him
yeah that was a good one it's a block
it's not always about scoring time so
that's true it's not always about the
ball David Tom David Gerard yes threw
the touchdown okay you ever talked to
Shawn Merriman about that you know it's
kind of that thing when you see someone
he's kind of give him the knowledge you
know you know what time it is help you
out a little bit that's awesome what's
your biggest takeaway from yesterday Oh
mr. Farrell I think any given Sunday if
you have a good game playing together
you believe you can win and I call the
Rams game so I saw the Seahawks come out
and start fast and and try to get after
the Rams a little bit then you know you
look up on the scoreboard and also you
see the Titans up 24 on the Patriots and
then I see my Jags who I felt you know
what had a bounce-back week with
fournette they played better but
couldn't find a way to win against the
coach so I just any given Sunday really
that that really last Sunday was kind of
the title for it I guess yeah but I've
asked you about this before with the
Rams
we know the offense is great it's the
the defense and it takes a while for
when you bring in parts to make a
defense work here
are you know fowler had contributed you
know Peters did okay
Donald is awesome but what's the biggest
concern about that Rams defense it's to
leave
I keep to leave is the guy he's the
piece that makes it all go which is
crazy to say that that corner but when
two leaves there you don't have Peters
following guys you could play sides
which is more most comfortable I want to
say on the on the left side of the yeah
I want to say it's either the right side
of the left side officer on whichever
one but then you could put it to leave
on the number one wide receiver and let
Marcus Peters kind of bounce around and
follow who he wants to follow and then
everyone's comfortable and what to leave
there the team is gonna hold because now
they're gonna be like are we're gonna
throw it at Marcus Peters well then you
put safety up there and it kind of
allows that pass rush to get to him and
and and again you know anytime you lose
or start in corner starting anything
you're putting a guy that's normally not
in the game in the game and teams are
gonna go after him
where would you place Jared golf with
the young quarterbacks um I think after
these last these the last two years he
has to be in the top two top three top
two top three of of quarterbacks period
golf is in the top two or three yeah I
mean if we saw the way you saw the way
he played against New Orleans that he
had the one pick but other than that he
went right down the field when they
played the Vikings defense he torched
them right now he's playing with we call
uber confidence he's just he doesn't
matter who they're going against coach
McVeigh is still a ton of confidence in
him and that often so they can go out
and score on anybody and when you see
him he doesn't so I saw him in college I
trained at Cal worked out with him there
I saw him in his first year in Los
Angeles where he was quiet he you know
he wasn't a real bosphorus kind of guy
he's still not boasters but you could
tell in his interviews he's much more
confident his abilities and what he can
do and that's the biggest difference to
me is just he's confident he knows he
can make these throws he's confident
where he's going with the ball and you
know when he has confidence that offense
plays but and I think that's the when
you look at the Saints that's what it is
they're confident Drew Brees is gonna
make every throw every play and that
game was fascinating watching him go
back and forth you know coming back from
21 down going up 21 like they were
finding ways and battling in so many
different areas
both quarterbacks played exceptional
who's the MVP right now if I said
mahomes
Holmes oh yes okay it's a court let's be
honest it's a quarterback award so let's
not even throw running backs in there
how does that for what well girly
girlies he should he should win in the
top three
he should win it but it's a quarterback
award you know he's why won't he win it
because you know he has I want to say
girly has 17 touchdowns and nine games
or whatever maybe eight games but
Mahone's has close to thirty already so
the stats which is gonna be so far out
there with the new rules in a way you
could throw the ball maybe Patrick where
Holmes is on fire right now so you just
have to you know try to hold off and
then you have Drew Brees only throwing
one interception and 20 touchdowns the
quarterback numbers are just so close
ooh it's too easy for them right it just
is I mean you know Phillip Rivers having
a great game their great season yeah I
think it's I I'm always surprised when I
see somebody struggle when you see
somebody who is throwing three or four
interceptions or you're not throwing for
300 yards well it kind of shows your
your ability I feel like as a
quarterback with all the new rules
yeah when you can't throw touchdowns or
throw you're throwing a lot of picks one
is you I feel like you're having the
trouble reading defenses which you know
as a quarterback that's the first thing
you have to people do they anticipate
they throw but then really after that
it's you know you don't have to be
aggressive all the time like there's
some guys that are crazy aggressive and
they'll throw the ball but there's guys
like Tom Brady and Drew Brees who are
ultra conservative as well they do take
their shots when they present themselves
but for the most part they'll check the
ball down and let guys go and so when
you're throwing picks this is because
you're trying to prove to someone or
prove that you can be this guy when you
really don't have to in this league I
was listening to the Rams game yesterday
and they had an audible and they yelled
out Hallie bear I'm a gun that was
phenomenal
okay did you ever have an autumn like
anything fun when you were playing where
somebody yells out hey we had a my
rookie year the coaches so I chose youth
football now and it's funny you can say
whatever you want I think I'm gonna put
this play in the play was called brown
shoe it wasn't fun like Halle Berry
anything like that but brown shoe is was
it was the the formation emotion and the
play all in one and all he had to yell
was brown shoe and everyone knew what
they were doing
so we put in a thing I'm not gonna give
you the name because I don't work we
have a game this weekend I want it I
don't want the listeners that came to
hear me but we put it in and it's like
total chaos it's like a hurry-up offense
in a way and all the parents like do you
think this is gonna work I was like oh
it's football anything works you can say
whatever you want so let's say if it was
Dan Patrick the name of the deal they
all like whatever they as soon as we
yell it they all get to the line of
scrimmage they run the circuit play but
it's like ten year old so everyone's all
over the place as soon as they hear it
it's like oh that's the word that's the
word that's where they all get set and
they go so I mean you can even you
didn't have any place like this when you
when you played like nothing fun not
Halle Berry actually I tweeted at Jared
after that like you know the one the one
who doesn't shoot his shot will never
win so you got to shoot your shot in
that situation right just I don't know
where I heard it from but it sounded
like like something real wait wait who's
taken it who thinks they have a shot at
the Halle Berry crown here well Jared he
tweeted at her and was like it's my
favorite play a shot young man
I mean Jared Goff you've probably got a
girlfriend done having rings yet I think
you gotta have a ring if you ever gone
there you know I think if you're if
you're you're Jared golf me she's first
ballot hall-of-famer you can tell me
he's the king of LA right now him and
Todd they're kind of running that way a
little bit she you know she wants to get
back in the whole movie industry deal
you know get you a young hot young young
one in solid make it get you it gets her
name back up there she's it's like Joe
Montana yeah you can coach but I I
thought it was fun but it was quiet
though right so when you heard it now
did you know what the play was no they
they that's the one thing they don't
share information no you can't even get
close to that you came again don't even
bother with that so you do the games but
you you can't find out any kind of hints
that you want to give to the audience
during the game not not that close all
right we try to you know I I understand
the importance of having you know plays
that you've never ran and yeah those
type of things I mean there was why I
don't know what play that was to be
exactly I know
it's a play where they gave Robert woods
like a reverse sweep inside or trap play
and you don't want to be the guy to
spill the beans on that and then they
get stopped then cosmic vase all upset
with you you know he's Maurice
jones-drew his Twitter handle is at MJD
Thursday Night Football continues this
week Packers Seahawks on Fox NFL Network
and Amazon Prime video Dallas Cowboys we
saw offensive line you know what they're
gonna be like none week there they're
really good in another week they're just
like who is this why I think the
offensive line getting healthy like I
think that's big for them Zack Martin I
thought played a great game yeah I mean
he went out though and came back you
know to me it really comes down to Zeek
if they can get Zeke going or not cuz
when Zeke touches the ball he's able to
be that type of player that's when
you're gonna see you know the Cowboys go
but you have a league that is really
predicated on offenses you know being
driven by quarterbacks here right so
you're asking this offense to be running
back driven and complemented by your
quarterback yeah you know you have to
know who you are like I can't you know
grant I want to have my own talk show
one day and be like you and you those
things but I can't wear your clothes I
can't wear glasses I got LASIK so I'm
good I'll need those other things you
know I don't my hair is there you know I
mean though I can't be you and I'm
thinking this league that's what you
have to understand is who you are as a
team and really focus on that and and
some teams aren't passing teams some
teams aren't you know explosive team
some teams right now just a first-round
pick you brought into Maury Cooper
you're trying to build that but if
you're not that right now is dak
Prescott that kind of quarterback though
that I can load him up for 30 passes a
game no he's got a 30 passing game I
think he's 22 to 25 every quarterback
has their pitch count but I think what
you could use DAC or other people you
can't is raise his legs let him run he's
young he's a big back let him run let
him do different things be creative in
that standpoint how you saw him run the
option you know those are things you can
you can do teams aren't used to that so
you could be creative in those ways
where some teams you can't you can't run
the option right you can't do certain
things so understanding your personnel
and take advantage of those things and I
think that's how you be creative and
that's how you utilize your offens
instead of trying to make him something
he's not
when you do that you get those those bad
games like against the Tennessee Titans
and those type of things and then you
know Scott Linehan just when you're in
it anytime you're in the like red zone
tight red zone ten yard line
just turn around to hand the ball off to
Z like let's stop getting fancy and try
to throw these these routes in these
crazy combinations just turn around I
hand the ball off
we've had some spirited conversations
about Le'Veon Bell oh now you you should
nominal conversations usually you share
the same agent yeah we do okay so you
I'm guessing you have some inside
information here because I mean so I've
always given people would the process of
what was going on not really the because
it slave yawns decision it's there's no
one else is gonna make this decision but
labia and I think do you think he plays
this year I wouldn't play this year but
do you thought oh I don't know if he
will or if he won't I mean I know he's
back in Pittsburgh but you have to know
talking to his agent you wouldn't by
doing your job by not that doesn't you
know my job I'm not I'm not Ian Rapoport
or Adams you've had strong opinions on
levy on Bill and and you're always well
researched you do your homework you're
well thought out and that's why oh yeah
I think you know what's going I really
don't know there's a rapport saying that
he won't there was a report that the the
Steelers owner said they can't wait to
have him back on Tuesday expect him back
then a couple hours later they're like
we don't expect him back I I really
don't know what's going on I haven't
talked to lady and I've talked today our
agent and you know our agent has done a
great job of giving him all the
information that he can so he could make
a business decision what's best for him
but I always tell people because you
know people in our in our in our society
in our in our world in our country are
so quick to judge and said like why
would have did this or I would have did
that and I have to go back to Mark
Zuckerberg at Facebook who was offered
two billion dollars early in the in the
start of Facebook and he turned it down
not many people would have done that
right I mean granted I feel like I
would've been one to be like no I know
my worth I know what my company's worth
I know what I'm worth yet you take your
two billion and go and I just actually
this morning on the way here I looked up
how much Facebook is where I think how
much is worth probably about sixty
billion you sure try double that 138
billion no is it yes so knowing your
worth is huge in this world and I mean
once you get past 60 then me
there really doesn't but I mean you're
right it really doesn't but this is a
138 billion it's crazy and I think
knowing your worth in this in this world
is huge it's one it's one of the things
that you can you you have the right to
try to justify and I think Le'Veon has
done that he's understood he understands
his worth it's a little trickier with
the NFL than it is it's very simple I
think it is I think Facebook because
it's all evaluations and where they may
go and those type of things but I think
with football it's much easier you know
if player X has this many stats and this
and he's getting paid you know why but
player Z has less stats would you pay
him more than Todd Gurley I'd pay him
what Todd girls getting paid I think
Todd Gurley is younger so granted Todd
Gurley he doesn't have the stats that
lay beyond his head but that's what
around there and what I would pay him
cuz I know I'm gonna get receiving
options out of them as well as running
but he's not gonna get the 14 million
back if you're gonna pay him what you're
paying Todd Gurley well guess what
Zuckerberg I gotta get the two billion
back no it's not the same no no you're
not gonna get that money back but you
but at the so he gave me he's got 14 and
he's gonna get you know horny 45 years
so you wouldn't give a 14 to get 45 I
understand if you're gonna try to be
healthy I get it right I mean that's but
you're not getting the money back is
what I'm right now and I think that's
where people that's where people get
messed up if he goes out there in plays
and we've seen the Earl Thomas we've
seen Dez Bryant we see all these guys
get hurt if they're older came back from
a knee injury in college yes
so I I think Le'Veon well I don't think
he's gonna play this year I understand
why he doesn't but he's not gonna make
that money back he's not gonna get Dale
Beckham jr. money
I mean he's not he doesn't play that
position that he thinks he's an
entertainer like I'm owed else an
entertainer I think that's what his
agent I think Le'Veon thinks that he is
and I've talked to lady and I think lady
on thinks and knows that that he is the
ultimate weapon because though he's not
he's not just a running back he's a guy
that can do everything and he's a big
mismatch on the field imagine imagine
whoever whatever team was to say he goes
back to Pittsburgh let's just throw this
out there so people
people gonna say he goes back imagine
putting James Connor in the back foot
him and wide receiver in the slot I know
he's got a starting wide receiver
exactly absolutely so in that situation
you have a guy who could play both
positions and at a high level
he needs get compensated as such very
simple no right or wrong he's not gonna
make the money back that's it he's I
agree with you that he's gonna make the
money back so and he wants to be healthy
for the next contract I get it he might
miss out on a Super Bowl as well this is
the business I know it's a business
decision right
I mean you throw down if you want to
drive I personally don't want to do
anything like that
there you go going back to the old
school I don't do those things like try
to get away from that and I sometimes
sometimes you press my button I don't
know why I'm we're talking about LAIV
yeah we just say anything about each
other but it felt it feels like it's you
it's like I was attacking a little bit
no not at all why would I do such a
thing I I grew up on the tracks not when
I talked to you about the high school
and the rivalry you you tried to give me
this whole runaround thing you all right
all right take a break here it's good to
see you it's always great thanks for
getting no problem anything anything for
you it just don't touch me that's all I
ask
right and we cool with that yeah all
right Maurice jones-drew NFL Network
analyst for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]